le cross une passion pour hélène watier
un virus que lui a transmis il ya 25 ans
son enseignante devenu aujourd'hui sa
coach
nathalie carrière aujourd'hui on va
essayer de faire sauter after eight
l'amt peuvent sur le sur le guet dans sa
première fois qu'il est sur le cross
une complicité qui a permis à la
cavalière instructrice diplômés
d'intégrer le haut niveau et l'équipe de
france de concours complet
un résultat qui ne doit rien au hasard
énormément de travail de la part des
laines aussi bien dans le club que sur
le travail des chevaux beaucoup de
rester dspo un travail en continu
et puis une volonté d'acier et puis une
complicité que les chevaux voile et
rennes sont pas encore tout à fait
tendues de filet ça veut dire qu'il
n'est pas encore assez way actif le
quotidien d'hélène ce sont les leçons
qu'elle dispense aux cavaliers des
écuries du val de l'eure près de
chartres je leur transmets tout ce que
j'ai appris tout ce que je vis tous les
stages que je fais j'ai c'est de pouvoir
leur transmettre toutes mes expériences
en compétition pareille pour que après
même à petit niveau il puisse justement
être performant parmi les chevaux de
cette reprise
il y as jubal 19 ans celui qui a permis
à hélène d'accéder au niveau
international en concours complet
ça restera mon cheval qui est pas qu il
m'appartient pas parce qu'il appartient
au club mais quand je parle de coeur le
le plus gros que j'ai des puces avec mes
pages badminton beurlay chez tous les
plus beaux concours angleterre c'était
mon rêve d'y aller mais la monture avec
laquelle elle va tenter de se qualifier
pour les jeux olympiques c'est lui quito
de balles hier un cheval de 11 ans
achetez lui aussi pour le club je
trouvais sympa un grand échalas je me
suis dit ça ça doit on va avoir bien
s'entendre
mon rêve ce serait d'aller faire les
europe et les jeux
à rio ça serait vraiment mon rêve de
gosse
première victoire pour hélène elle vient
d'intégrer la liste des présélectionnés
pour les championnats d'europe qui
auront lieu cet été à aix la chapelle en
allemagne